sí
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález la decisión
de nicolás maduró de expedir un decreto
que le permitió la liberación de 110
opositores entre los que hay políticos
periodistas activistas entre otros se ha
convertido en un nuevo punto de
discusión entre la oposición venezolana
y la oposición de ese país que se sigue
mostrando fragmentada y se debate entre
participar en los comicios
parlamentarios de diciembre o
boicotearlos
en este escenario surgen muchas
preguntas en torno al ambiente político
que se está viviendo en venezuela que
hay detrás de esta decisión que ha
tomado nicolás maduro de liberar a estos
opositores detenidos que pasa con la
oposición porque se incrementa el cisma
se alejan de las posiciones cuando
deberían tener un objeto común un
objetivo común que he hecho es así cuál
es el panorama político que se está
viviendo en venezuela que busca el
gobierno lo vamos a analizar aquí en el
debate de france 24 y para eso hemos
invitado a natasha rojas ella es docente
de relaciones internacionales en la
pontificia universidad javeriana
se conecta a este debate desde la ciudad
de bogotá en colombia también está con
nosotros paulina fighting ella es
abogada profesora de activista de
derechos humanos se encuentra en la
ciudad de lima en perú y también va a
participar en esta mesa víctor mijares
profesor de ciencia política de la
universidad de los andes también se
conecta a este debate desde la ciudad de
bogotá la capital colombiana también
queremos conocer cuáles son sus
opiniones y sus preguntas pueden unirse
a este debate a través de las redes
sociales france24 yo en el piso s y a
santi lobo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate
efe 24 pues tenemos el tema tenemos
muchas preguntas por delante quiero
comenzar con la talla natasha gracias
por estar de nuevo aquí en france 24 y
cuál puede ser entonces desde su punto
de vista la estrategia de nicolás maduro
que hay detrás de esta liberación de
este indulto dado por el presidente del
gobierno de venezuela
yo creo que hay dos líneas que están
relacionadas con esta decisión de
nicolás maduró por un lado seguir el
juego la idea de legitimar estas
supuestas elecciones ante la comunidad
internacional y por otro lado porque
constantemente sabe que cuando hace ese
tipo de acciones frente a la oposición
logra dividirlas y en este caso como
bien estaban comentando la división
frente a la posibilidad de participar o
no en el proceso
y paulina desde la capital peruana su
opinión cuál sería la estrategia de
nicolás maduró para haber realizado
haber expedido este decreto de haber
liberado a estos 110 opositores
bueno nicolás maduros lo que nos dio a
conocer el 31 de agosto no fue una
liberación de presos políticos y en el
cual da dos mensajes uno interno y el
externo hacia la comunidad internacional
lo que está el mensaje que está enviando
es que él no es tan malo que él no es
tan rígido que él no es tan dictador y
que está tan dispuesto a liberar a estas
personas que han sido catalogados como
presos políticos y al nivel interno lo
que está buscando definitivamente es
lograr fraccionar aún más a la unidad
que ya ha estado lamentablemente
fraccionada a pesar de que toda la
unidad y yo creo que la mayoría de los
venezolanos tenemos un objetivo común
una talla que tanto le puede creer la
comunidad internacional a estas
verdaderas o supuestas intenciones que
tienen nicolás maduro más allá de los
países que han respaldado su gobierno
como rusia como china como turquía irán
la comunidad internacional como está
viendo esta acción por parte del
gobierno en caracas
pero creo que aunque parezca increíble e
incluso con lo con la actualización del
informe del alto comisionado de naciones
unidas creíamos que este tipo de
estrategias ya no producían los efectos
que ellos creen en la comunidad
internacional creo que las noticias de
los últimos días incluso el
pronunciamiento de la alta comisionada
indican que aún funciona y como bien
acaban de comentar esto da la señal que
es el régimen el que quiere negociar y
si la oposición no se acerca ya es esta
oposición la que van a empezar a
catalogar también de ser antidemocrática
y parece que el juego les empieza a
funcionar un poco al menos al mover la
opinión pública donde todos si hablan de
precios políticos hablan como si
realmente se hubiese producido un
indulto en este caso
paulina en materia de derechos humanos
esto como beneficia venezuela que es un
país fuertemente señalado por los
organismos internacionales precisamente
por violar los derechos humanos la
oposición también los ha criticado desde
diferentes ángulos en torno a este tema
este indulto si se le puede llamar
verdaderamente un indulto como se toman
en la materia de derechos humanos a
nivel internacional como entender esto
bueno lo primero que hay que decir es
que esto no se trata muy indulto desde
el punto de vista estrictamente jurídico
y legal no se trata los indultos los
otorga siempre un juez perdón siempre el
presidente de la república pero tiene
que haber una sentencia firme de un juez
y en estos casos solamente siete casos
tienen sentencia de los 110 personas más
que fueron encarceladas que no todos
estaban en prisión recordemos que
algunos se encontraban en embajadas por
ejemplo como la de chile que es el caso
de freddy llegan ahora hay otras
personas que tenían procesos abiertos
más ninguno solamente siete personas no
estaban sentenciadas entonces llamar
indultos cómo tratar desde el punto de
vista estrictamente jurídico es
incorrecto debería decirse sobre
seguimientos de causa pero el sobre
seguimiento de causa lo tienen que dar
el poder judicial y no el poder
ejecutivo como se ha dado en venezuela
en cuanto a los derechos humanos yo creo
que es no solamente porque los
activistas no hemos denunciado una y mil
veces sino porque ya hay informes
contundentes de la violación sistemática
de derechos humanos en venezuela
realizados por la alta comisionada de
derechos humanos la doctora bachelet de
naciones unidas entonces naciones unidas
han sido la violación sistemática de
derechos humanos la existencia de presos
políticos y lamentablemente el hablar
aparte de la comunidad internacional
está viendo esto como algo positivo
desde el punto de vista meramente humano
obviamente nosotros celebramos como
activismo como activistas que estas
personas hayan sido liberadas porque
están injustamente apresados la talla ya
retomó con ustedes el tema político
quiero hacerle una última pregunta
paulina en torno a este tema de los
derechos humanos
usted lo decía llevan varios años
registrándose violaciones de los
derechos humanos han quedado en los
informes de los organismos
internacionales ustedes
cristaldo se han registrado así pero
esto puede considerarse como un primer
paso tal vez para cambiar un poco esa
imagen que está teniendo el gobierno de
nicolás maduro se puede borrar ese largo
historial que tiene venezuela de
violación de los derechos humanos con la
liberación de 110 presos
los delitos de lesa humanidad y de
violación de derechos humanos y más los
que se han cometido en venezuela que son
violaciones sistemáticas a los derechos
humanos no se pueden borrar con con una
acción de este tipo en estos momentos
hay 386 presos políticos más registrados
y hablar político y ex presos políticos
registrados porque hay personas
desaparecidas que no sabemos dónde están
en estos momentos y no sabemos están en
los calabozos de algunas de las cárceles
o si están en otros lugares o si han
sido asesinados entonces la cifra
oficial según el foro penal venezolano
que viene haciendo los estudios
importantes al respecto son 386 muertos
mil 386 presos políticos perdón entonces
la situación
yo creo que limpie el nombre de nicolás
maduro como violador de derechos humanos
y como la
desde hoy digamos que en venezuela no
habían presos políticos porque siguen
habiendo presos políticos y
lamentablemente van a seguir habiendo
presos políticos mientras tengamos un
régimen de este tipo dirigiendo al
gobierno venezolano o al régimen
venezolano como debe decírselo yo hago
la aclaración que cuando digo borrar
pues claramente esto está en los
informes de los organismos
internacionales
lo digo es porque olvidamos rápido
entonces dejamos de lado como sociedad
este tipo de hechos y empezamos a darle
una nueva mirada a a estos
acontecimientos que están pasando
recientemente pero los hechos y las
violaciones están en los informes de los
organismos internacionales y pues de ahí
son imborrables hago esa aclaración y
natasha retomo la conversación con usted
y hay una pregunta que surge y queda en
la mesa y es una gran preocupación fuera
de las fronteras de venezuela y es la
división de la oposición nuevamente
están otra vez fragmentados nuevamente
hay
tiros de un lado hacia el otro entre
maría corina machado henrique capriles y
juan guaidó que es el presidente de la
asamblea nacional porque se mantienen
estas diferencias porque es el objetivo
es común porque no hay una unidad y
porque este tipo de hechos fragmenta más
una imagen de lo que constantemente ha
ocurrido tratando incluso de
convencernos de la unidad pero en
términos reales nunca la hemos vivido
este fraccionamiento digamos que es lo
que ha hecho es tener una clara visión
una clara frontera con los de los
últimos años y claramente aquí hay un
tratado que como bien decía olvidamos
muchas cosas que hace el régimen y
olvidamos lo que ocurrió en las últimas
elecciones legislativas donde si bien la
oposición decide participar y ganar la
mayoría de los escaños después ellos
hacen uso de un tribunal hacen uso del
poder judicial para invalidar todas sus
decisiones una asamblea que durante todo
su ejercicio ha estado desvalida y
rompiendo todo el estado de derecho
entonces creo que si tenemos claro que
en venezuela no hay estado de derecho
que estamos hablando de un régimen no
democrático es muy difícil pensar que
una salida electoral es posible y creo
que ese ha sido el digamos el gran
debate en la oposición también un poco
llevado por la misma presión
internacional donde buena parte de la
internacional como bien decía paulina va
a generar ese efecto de creer que el
régimen en esta ocasión si quiere
negociar quiere acercarse quiere diálogo
y vuelve a generar esta división de como
se viene dando como este apoyo que
continuamente lo hemos vivido en los
últimos años incorporó esta conversación
a víctor mijares que lo presente al
inicio del programa ya está con nosotros
él es profesor de ciencia política de la
universidad de los andes en la ciudad de
bogotá
víctor gracias por estar aquí en
france24 le estaba preguntando a natasha
por qué se mantiene esta división y este
cisma se incrementa entre la oposición
cuando el objetivo es el mismo es que
nicolás maduró deje el poder y dé paso a
una transición democrática en el país
hola que tal buenas noches bueno puedo
dar muchísimas razones razones
visiones estratégicas encontradas
distintos paradigmas mentales en cuanto
a ideología lo que se quiere realmente
también obviamente competencia entre
liderazgos que nos permite esa
coordinación esa coordinación que nos
parece a todos tan obvia quizás no sea
tan clara venezuela
digamos tiene un como casi todos los
países verdad en un espectro ideológico
bastante amplio con unas visiones muy
distintas pero además recordemos que
desde hace muchísimo tiempo de
caballería yo el chavismo viene
construyendo
la idea de una oposición leal una
posición leal que digamos estimula a
través de ciertos premios a otra digamos
desleal que la castilla naturalmente y
esto va generando entonces una situación
en la cual pueda tratar de sostenerse y
tratar de legitimarse a través de
elecciones pero que no sean elecciones
realmente competitivas elecciones en
donde realmente pueda perder no sólo el
tipo de elección que se se plantean en
el caso venezolano entonces a través de
estos sistemas y de las divisiones y los
distintos liderazgos esté en pugna
dentro de venezuela resulta digamos
natural diría yo en común y casi todos
los esquemas autoritarios que se
desarrolla este tipo de distinciones y
de contradicciones dentro del liderazgo
opositor
paulina sigo con usted en este escenario
que describe víctor de esta construcción
de una oposición y también que haya
garantías o facilidades para que el
nicolás maduro simplemente a través de
las urnas pueda validar este
el nuevo legislativo que podría ser
elegido después del 6 de diciembre la
comunidad internacional que apoyó
entonces le apoyó le está dando a este
tipo de procedimientos electorales
teniendo en cuenta la falta de visión de
poderes que hay en venezuela
la comunidad internacional digamos los
países más importantes que son quienes
reconocen al precedente encargado cuando
yo ha manifestado públicamente a través
de comunicados que ellos desconocerían
este proceso electoral que pretende
instaurar nicolás maduro el 6 de
diciembre así lo ha hecho saber el grupo
lima
eeuu canadá que también es parte del
grupo lima la unión europea entonces
digamos que los países que apoyan al
presidente juan güell a lo que son más
de 60 países en estos momentos a nivel
mundial estaría no apoyarían digamos de
un proceso electoral en venezuela con
las condiciones que hoy hay no eso hay
que aclararlo porque obviamente los
venezolanos
queremos votar pero queremos votar en
unas condiciones
y legitimidad que requiere un proceso
electoral y dentro de las condiciones
que requiera un proceso electoral
justamente es la participación de
observadores internacionales y una larga
lista de cosas que deben cumplirse en
venezuela desde un nombramiento legal de
los rectores de ese proceso electoral y
el cumplimiento de la norma y la
legitimación de los partidos políticos
entre otras muchas cosas que hay que
tomar en consideración para llevar
adelante un proceso electoral
transparente equilibrado bajo la
normativa constitucional venezolana y
dentro de los parámetros internacionales
aceptables la talla de acuerdo a lo que
dice paulina entonces no hay garantías
y esto iría un poco en la línea que dice
juan guaidó de no presentarse en estas
condiciones a este proceso electoral
como también lo han dicho varios
partidos de la oposición y simplemente
no darle oportunidad a los venezolanos
de tener otra opción esto no sería un
escenario muy difícil
pero creo que es el único escenario
digamos que sería coherente con el
discurso que se trae desde hace algunos
años especialmente con la entrada en la
presidencia interina de juan guaidó y
repito si estamos hablando de un régimen
no democrático pues no podemos esperar
que se puedan medir en estos términos en
unas elecciones y viene la gran pregunta
de siempre ver cuáles son los incentivos
también al régimen para poder apostarle
a un tipo de transición entre comillas
en estos términos entonces no es no es
no ofrecerle nada a los venezolanos por
supuesto comparto la idea creo que el
escenario ideal sería una transición en
términos democráticos y lo menos
violenta posible pero con las
condiciones actuales no hay opción a
volverse a presentar y esto digamos
sería incoherente con lo que vienen
planteando en los últimos años porque si
yo estoy diciendo que aquí no hay estado
derecho no hay división de poderes no
hay garantías como es que yo me voy a
presentar un proceso desde el mismo
momento en que yo me presenta el proceso
empiezo darle validez y entonces cuando
los resultados no sean como lo que
esperábamos
vemos todos cuáles van a ser los
resultados las elecciones se van a dar
ganando las elecciones digamos en los
términos del régimen y sabemos los
resultados que van a tener entonces con
qué cara y con qué discurso se le va a
decir a la comunidad internacional que
esto fue fraudulento una talla eso eso
me llevaba a la posición que tiene
henrique capriles que él si está
apostando por participar no él porque
está inhabilitado para participar en
este tipo de comicios pero sí que los
venezolanos tengan alguna representación
de los partidos de oposición para tener
una opción para votar eso entonces rompe
con la intención y con lo que usted dice
participar es reconocer que ese proceso
es válido
y voy a la misma línea de lo que he
comentado adictos a participar por
supuesto nos van a permitir que este
tipo de oposición construida a su medida
y que ya lo tiene muy bien armado
incluso en elecciones anteriores les van
a dar participación para poderle llamar
oposición dentro del poder legislativo
pero en la práctica eso no va a ocurrir
y cuando medianamente tengan alguna
acción o alguna decisión no quieran
legislar sobre algún tema que no les sea
conveniente o que medianamente les en
como nuevamente van a hacer uso del
tribunal suprema de justicia para poder
bloquear cualquier tipo de decisión
víctor su opiniones frente a esta
división que hay de la oposición en este
punto de vista cuando dice no participar
henrique capriles la apuesta por
participar pero recordará hace unas
elecciones de mayo del 2018 que yo
estaba en el estudio estaba bush
discutiendo ese tema precisamente y
estaba en aquel momento se presentaron
entonces los resultados y se presentó
henri falcón en aquella oportunidad para
competir contra nicolás maduro pero lo
que quedó en evidencia al número de su
operación fue que falcón estado
efectivamente tratando de buscar un
espacio propio colonizar un espacio no
de conquista de poder a nivel de la
república verdad a nivel del estado sino
de conquistar el poder en el espacio que
permite el chavismo que existan ciertos
ciertos actores políticos que es ese
espacio de esa oposición construida de
su oposición leal pareciera no tengo
pruebas de eso pero pareciera que en
esta oportunidad es henrique capriles
quien está tratando de colonizar ese
espacio de desplazar al resto de sus
competidores en el contexto y en el
marco de la oposición no insisto para
hacerse con el poder en venezuela sino
lo que estamos viendo es una competencia
por el liderazgo en la oposición
entendiendo que sé
a tratar de permanecer con una posición
indefinidamente en un en un día un país
en donde hay que esto hay que hay que
entenderlo muy bien en un país en donde
como bien ha dicho la talla no hay
garantías de un estado de derecho no hay
posibilidad de una victoria electoral en
las condiciones actuales pero en donde
además a pesar de el declive por lo
dicho el colapso de la industria
petrolera es un país que sigue siendo
profundamente extractivista esos países
que son profundamente extractivista
ayunas en centralización del poder
político el poder económico y el poder
militar y en esa centralización lo que
vemos es una redistribución de renta de
la mano del estado de quien controla el
estado de la persona o el partido contra
el estado y a partir de aquí es por eso
que en estos países digamos
altamente extractivistas el lo normal es
es un régimen autoritario que distribuye
la renta
y distribuye ciertos beneficios
distribuye espacios políticos y permiten
la subsistencia de una oposición que se
acomoda a esa situación y que puede
tener algún tipo de beneficios en
materia política digamos controlando
algunas alcaldías y gobernaciones
teniendo alguna participación en la
asamblea nacional pero que la obteniendo
digamos porque tenemos alguna
participación en el sector económico que
es claramente dominado por el sector
público pero en donde no existe
posibilidades al menos a la vista de una
transición hacia la democracia en
venezuela no bajo este esquema y sería
una oposición prácticamente inofensiva
en ese escenario en ese eventual
escenario para esta siguiente ronda me
sigo con usted víctor me mantengo con
usted quiero preguntarle
por esos supuestos diálogos que han
estado supuestamente teniendo lugar
entre nicolás maduro o su gobierno con
el respaldo apoyo del gobierno de
turquía
henrique capriles ha dicho ya que no
participó en esa supuesta mesa de
diálogo no hay información al respecto
pero es en la información que se ha
movido en los medios de comunicación
puede haber una negociación detrás de
escena entre la oposición y este
gobierno que no sea oficial que esté
fuera como digo detrás de la escena
lo primero es la definición de oposición
que como ya sabemos está fragmentada
está dividida de distintas formas de
antes de hablar de oposición desde hace
mucho tiempo se ha tratado de la gran
lucha dentro de la oposición venezolana
o de los frentes opositores venezolanos
es crear efectivamente un único frente
con un liderazgo claro eso digamos ha
tenido distintas formas de organización
pero a la larga terminada termina
fallando termina fallando precisamente
porque bueno porque hay una capacidad de
el estado venezolano controlado por el
psv control en su momento por hugo
chávez luego por nicolás maduro una
capacidad de quebrantar esa unidad a
través de algunos digamos
premios castigos la posibilidad de abrir
espacios a ciertos grupos políticos pero
también ha habido una interesante y muy
importante forma de participación de
otros regímenes autoritarios que de
algún modo han servido también como
tenemos de exportadores de técnicas
autoritarias en el caso venezolano en
servicios de inteligencia cubanos por
ejemplo o las formas en las cuales
digamos mismo vladimir putin a plazo
aplastado su oposición en rusia han sido
formas también que se han practicado en
venezuela desde hace algún tiempo ahora
bien estas negociaciones hay una
negociación que podría abrir el espacio
que lo veo muy difícil incluso en el
caso de negociaciones con países
democráticos cómo se hace como sido el
caso por ejemplo de noruega y otros y
otros países interesados incluso ongs en
los eeuu tienen se han llevado adelante
una campaña muy fuerte para que se dé
esta negociación si esas negociaciones e
incapacidad tiene que ver precisamente
con las asimetrías de poder están
asimetrías de poder
como venezuela en donde
controla toda la oposición no controla
nada difícilmente puede llevar a algo
porque no hay en este momento capacidad
para que ninguna fuerza dentro de
venezuela y pareciera que no hay
voluntad para que ninguna fuerza fuera
de venezuela desplaza el chavismo en
esas condiciones pareciera bien que
cualquier forma de negociación sería
tratar de recobrar alguna sensatez
económica pero difícilmente desplazar el
chavismo como fuerza hegemónica y
venezuela
natasha su opinión sobre este tema de
las negociaciones comparte usted la
opinión de víctor que claramente no
no hay lugar para este tipo de escenario
de negociaciones mientras tras la escena
o podría de verdad darse ese escenario
creo que incluso no vuelve a pasar lo
que pasaba hace algunos meses volvemos y
vamos a mezclar la idea de negociación
con diálogo comparto la idea cuando se
habla de negociaciones porque ambas
partes tienen formas de presionar y
tienen formas digamos de buscar como el
otro puede acceder o de persuadir y en
este caso ese sector no tiene
absolutamente nada que ofrecerle al
régimen para que éste pueda acceder qué
es lo que se empieza que es lo que se ve
que se está dando en este momento
ciertas concesiones en masa tipo más a
modo individual digamos a ciertos a
ciertos actores políticos para no llamar
los líderes porque en ese sentido
todavía no tienen como esa comprensión o
esa dimensión pero sí hay ciertas
concesiones para esa posible
participación que les permita
deslegitimar cierto tipo de acciones
hacia afuera que muy bien decía a víctor
también tiene que ver mismo con los
temas económicos estamos hablando
también de un tipo de entre comillas
mediador que es lejos de ser democrático
entonces es lo que viene a reforzar ese
tipo
o de acercamientos en el sector pero lo
más preocupante es que hacia afuera si
se genera la imagen no parece estarse
generando la imagen que si es una
oposición en su unidad o en su
composición que pareciera estar
dispuesta a acercarse a dialogar con el
régimen
paulina su opinión en la ciudad de lima
la capital de perú en torno a este tema
de las supuestas negociaciones sobre
todo con un gobierno o un régimen como
lo puede llamar usted que incluso maría
corina machado ha dicho se ha burlado
del papá se ha burlado de la unión
europea ha convocado negociaciones y las
ha roto en diferentes oportunidades se
puede creer que de pronto más adelante
puede haber alguna mesa de negociación
entre las partes
mira la visión política que hemos visto
desde acá va desde lima no solamente de
política desde la mirada de venezuela de
los venezolanos sino de los políticos
peruanos es que no hay negociación sino
que lo que ocurrió fue una conversación
entre un líder reconocido venezolano dos
veces candidato a la presidencia de la
república que es henrique capriles
radonski y enseñar estar mi gonzález que
es representante del gobierno en la
transición del nación ya y que han
tenido una una hay una conversación para
la liberación de presos políticos pero
negociación como tal yo creo en enarsa
viendo en estos momentos no hay diálogo
sino entre la unidad propiamente dicho
sino un diálogo directo entre 12 líderes
y el régimen venezolano
y eso también lo que se está observando
políticamente desde acá desde lima y yo
creo que es como debe verlo o sea es una
intermediación por el preso político que
fueron liberados sólo esos me quedan
pocos minutos y quiero preguntarles por
juan guaidó en diciembre de termina su
periodo en la asamblea nacional llegó
con un plan de gobierno a este gobierno
interino que fue reconocido por más de
50 países alrededor del mundo y muchas
de las cosas que prometió no han tenido
lugar por diferentes motivos
precisamente por la capacidad
institucional que hay porque no hay una
división de poderes allí clara dentro
del escenario del chavismo que va a
suceder con juan guaidó que va a suceder
en venezuela a partir del 6 de diciembre
cuando tengan lugar esas elecciones
comienzo con paulina y esto nos sirve a
modo de conclusión para el cierre
bueno si esas elecciones se dan en el 6
de diciembre como tiene planteado el el
régimen establecerlo habría nuevos
diputados que representarían a la nueva
asamblea nacional
eso si fuéramos a un país completamente
democrático cosa que no sucede
recordamos que en venezuela
tenemos una situación muy sui generis
el periodo definitivamente de los
legisladores que hoy están ejerciendo
sus cargos entre ellos cuando según la
constitución acaba el 31 de diciembre
del 2020 eso es lo que establece la
constitución periodos de cinco años sin
embargo eeuu ya se ha adelantado a decir
que ellos continuarán reconociendo a
juan guaidó
hasta que permanezca este régimen
usurpador del poder según declaraciones
propias de sus voceros no desde el punto
de vista constitucional debería culminar
el 31 de diciembre del 2020 y esa es la
realidad constitucional en un país
democrático una talla minuto y medio
para su conclusión
no creo que vamos a seguir viviendo esta
institucionalidad paralela creo que las
elecciones en términos del régimen se
van a producir en muy acomodadas por
otro lado tenemos una asamblea que va a
continuar pero aquí el gran temor es que
nos pase algo muy parecido a cuba y
vamos a pasar décadas con una doble
institucionalidad con un presidente
incluso en el exilio como es el caso de
los cubanos pero que en la práctica no
están ni siquiera cerca de poder
detectar el poder y esto va a seguir
fraccionando más la oposición porque ya
hay voces donde dice que el periodo al
menos si la asamblea continúa hay que
darle relevo
a esa representación que está ejerciendo
juan guaidó víctor mijares en la ciudad
de bogotá su conclusión si aquí
movimiento depende de muchos factores
entre ellos y antes de llegar a ese
momento
desde enero del 2021 son las elecciones
de estados unidos y ver cómo queda el
balance de poder allá y aparte de eso
ver si cambia en el caso que se mantenga
tomando el poder que no parece ser un
escenario tuve claro si cambio no sé esa
estrategia hacia con miedo la práctica
digamos de práctica política de todo
esto es que en definitiva más allá de lo
que pueda decir o no la constitución hay
en este momento una situación
extraordinaria se ha generado esa
institucionalidad paralela digamos algo
que ha venido siendo el chavismo
históricamente que luego lo hizo la
oposición con esta estrategia de huelva
y dependerá sobre todo si se mantiene
ese apoyo internacional
ese apoyo internacional sin duda va a
ser importante para eso pero eso local
del balance de poder dentro del país
tenemos unos servicios de inteligencia y
contrainteligencia que están de la mano
de maduro tenemos en el control todavía
de lo poco que queda de la industria
petrolera colapsada tenemos el control
del extractivismo minero sobre todo en
materia de oro el apoyo de nuevos
regímenes digamos
de maduro es ayuda y está cooperación va
a ser fundamentales y por supuesto del
otro lado el temor de las potencias
occidentales de ser mal vistas por
generar una excesiva presión sobre el
gobierno de maduro o de mantener el
apoyo a un líder como con huevo en este
en este contexto lo que parecería lógico
para un líder como weibo sería decretar
un estado de emergencia que preséntese
en ese sentido jugar políticamente con
los principios constitucionales sin
plantear una situación en la cual no se
les restituirá entonces la asamblea
nacional hasta que no haya en definitiva
un cambio político en venezuela que
permite elecciones libres casamientos
invitados muchas gracias por haber
estado hoy en el debate de france 24
ustedes pueden continuar dejando sus
preguntas y sus comentarios en las redes
sociales sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]